the nation will fall silent at 11
o'clock today remembering all those who
made the ultimate sacrifice in service
of this country
her majesty the queen will be at the
cenotaph to lead the national
remembrance day service
it'll be particularly poignant for
general sonic carter the chief of the
defence staff who will soon retire from
that role and from the british army
which he joined back in 1977.
there's been no shortage of major issues
for him to contend with in the last few
years and when i spoke to him at the
royal hospital chelsea i started by
asking about the most pressing
afghanistan and how he felt about the
chaotic withdrawal of western
troops it was tough um it wasn't the
outcome that any of us wanted
um and we hoped right up until the end
that the
afghan government and its armed forces
would be able to
hang in there and create the sort of
circumstances in which you could get a
proper political reconciliation so for
all of us it was tough and of course for
those who fought in afghanistan against
the taliban who now are in power that
was particularly difficult because of
course they were the enemy at the time
it must take a lot for soldiers now
having fought in the way that they did
you did in afghanistan
to
have to talk to the taliban
is that what we have to do now
um we certainly have to engage them for
a number of reasons i mean first and
foremost there are still afghans who
worked with us who we are worried will
be the subject of vendettas and we would
like to see them find a way out of
afghanistan and we would like to look
after them to achieve that
secondly we're very worried about the
humanitarian situation in afghanistan
and that's been in the media this week
and in order to resolve that one has to
engage with the taliban government to
try and make sure the money gets to
where it needs to get to
and then i think also
we need to engage with them to get them
to understand that they need to govern
inclusively um because many of the gains
that we made in the 20 years that we
were engaged there we could lose if they
don't govern inclusively and the rights
of women the opportunity for girls to go
to school
and the rights of all minorities in
afghanistan need to be properly
respected and if that doesn't happen
then the answer is that we will have
failed it must be a bitter pill to
swallow though for
not you but someone like you to have to
sit down opposite
both people that you fought against and
also people that frankly
in what they
want to do what they did before when
their government
feels abhorrent
yes but but i think
we've all been around long enough to
know that wars generally end in a
conversation and they generally end with
a compromise
now if afghanistan turns out in five
years time to be a country that is being
governed inclusively in which the rights
of all of its people are properly
respected then i think we can look back
on our intervention in afghanistan with
some satisfaction there's a big if at
the front end of that and if that means
that we have to talk to people that we
originally regarded as the enemy then so
be it it's tough to do but let's face it
that's how we achieve peace in northern
ireland
before they came into government this
time the taliban said
we're different
do you really believe that
um i think they have definitely done
some that some things already that are
different i mean the fact that the media
is still being allowed to operate and to
report relatively honestly in
afghanistan is a good indicator
it is still the case that women are not
in the government and are not going to
secondary education but they are going
to primary education and that is
different to what they did in the past
um so there are things that are going on
in afghanistan which are definitely
different to what they were
20 years ago
and that i think is because
this taliban government should we call
it taliban too rather than taliban one
they recognize that 60 of afghans have
been born since 2001 and that's a very
large proportion of the population
who've seen a slightly different country
to the one that predated 2001 and the
taliban at the end of the day know that
they have got to take people with them
if they're going to govern effectively
they can't govern completely brutally
that just won't work in the modern
environment because the thing that's
really changed is social media and
modern media and they can't put that
back in the box are you in favor of the
kind of inquiry perhaps a public inquiry
into
afghanistan
exercise well i think we need to be
clear that i think unlike iraq nobody i
think was in any doubt that the
reason for entering afghanistan in the
first place was just there was a
unanimous security council resolution
indeed article 5 of the nato treaty uh
was placed on the table so i don't think
anybody's in any doubt that it was a
just war
i think there are some big questions
that need to be answered about how the
war was conducted thereafter
and those are lessons that both
policymakers and military figures and
for that matter more broadly the
development community need to learn
whether the right way of achieving that
is through a public inquiry or i don't
know because i don't think this is about
portioning blame or anything like that
this is about making sure that we all
learn from the experience so that next
time we have to do something like this
we do it better than we did this time
you said that you could imagine
afghanistan being a tourist destination
really
well what i was trying to say is that in
the great swathe of history you know
nobody would have thought uh in the late
1970s that vietnam would ever be a place
that westerners would go on holiday
you know 50 years downstream vietnam is
an extraordinarily successful country
the point i'm trying to make is give
everything time are we in danger of
entering a new cold war with china
no i don't think we are
and indeed i don't think that's the
right direction to travel now i think we
everybody recognizes that um this
century is going to be the asian century
and that china is going to be at the
heart of that
and that there are going to be many
areas where we need to work with china
and indeed engage with china and trade
with china because that's where the
economic value is going to come from i
think we will also observe that there
are things that china does which we
don't approve of uh china's human rights
record the way it's behaving with the
wigars and with hong kong are things
that we will absolutely call them out on
what could we possibly do to defend
taiwan
um well there's some big questions there
about whether it's our task to defend
taiwan
um and that's not something that i'm
going to opine on because these are
political judgments i mean i think what
i would say as a military officer
is that ultimately we want to make sure
that we don't go to war over issues like
that uh because that would not be in
anybody's interests and your advice is
it would be plausible
for the military in whatever
configuration
to defend taiwan against uh chinese
aggression the answer is that i have not
considered it yet and i think you know
my military advice is always going to be
to try and avoid going to war the
um former mi6 officer christopher steele
told sky news that russian leaders
believe that they're at war with the uk
and its allies that makes sense to you
do you agree with that well i think that
russia
probably regards the
global strategic context as a continuous
struggle
uh in which i think they would apply all
of the instruments of national power uh
to achieve their objectives
but in so doing don't want to bring on a
hot war
so yes i think in a way he's right the
question of course is how you define war
and i would tend as a soldier would tend
to define war as the actual act of
combat and fighting and i think they
don't want to do that i think they want
to try and achieve their objectives in
rather more nuanced ways let's talk
about the armed services that you are
leaving behind as you retire
are they fit for purpose
point i guess is is what you think their
purpose is
and if you believe that we're here to
deter war from happening then my
judgment is that
our armed forces are very much fit for
deterring our enemies of course one has
to remember that we do this in an
alliance we do it in nato nato is the
bedrock of our security and
fundamentally we see our security being
delivered through
that european relationship at the heart
of nato and the answer is that we are
very much uh leaders within nato and i'm
pretty confident that we're well
prepared to do what we have to do as
part of that nato alliance the secretary
of state complains that um women are
still unlikely to get to the most senior
roles in the armed services uh
do you agree and if so
uh i suppose he would be saying this is
a failure on the part of you and your
colleagues
um
yes i mean the facts are clear we do not
have enough women at the top of the
armed forces we have more than we did
have but we don't have enough and
there's a reason for that
and that's because the armed forces are
a bottom fed organization
and um if you think
back a few years it was only in 2016
when i was the chief of the general
staff took the decision to open all
roles up to women in the army including
the combat roles and up until that point
you know 60
of the roles in the army were available
to women but not all of them so it was
difficult of course for women to rise up
through the ranks in order to be able to
get to the highest possible ranks
i think we've done a lot to try and
adjust the career structure as well
because the career structure is one that
frankly was designed for men
and we've had to change that and we are
changing it
to make it easier for women if they wish
to raise families to take time out to do
that and then to be promoted based upon
their potential rather than what they do
during their 30s as that's the sort of
typical age that we're talking about
but fundamentally it's also about
culture and what we have to do is to
create a culture in the armed forces
which
looks to maximize everybody's talent and
not to be exclusive in the way it does
it the nature of warfare is changing i
mean is laddishness necessarily part of
modern warfare one man equally argue
geekishness is part of modern warfare
when i talk about there's a difference
between the nature of war which is a
political act it's about combat it's
about fighting and it's about
human interaction in a violent way the
character of warfare is different and
that's where you bring in geekinish
cyber and all these other things i still
believe that it will be necessary for
soldiers in the final analysis to have
to go close and personal with each other
in order to achieve an outcome if you
are fighting a genuine war and that is
the nature of war so the answer is that
it will still be necessary to have
people who are prepared to do that a
tenfold increase in reports of rape by
teenagers in the armed forces which
you've yourself said are truly shocking
if if we keep that idea that we have to
have
these warriors this type of warriors is
it a consequence of that that we're
going to
have to live with that kind of
i don't even call it behavior
no we're absolutely not going to live
with that sort of behavior because what
we're going to do is to make sure that
our values and standards which are well
understood are properly enforced and
we're absolutely going to make sure that
the leaders in the armed forces
understand those valleys and standards
and recognize that it is their task on
the one hand to make sure that we are
capable of fighting if we have to fight
but on the other hand that we're capable
of building inclusive teams in which
everybody feels respected a key value
and in which everybody feels that
through being included they're able to
contribute to our ultimate purpose
and that is why
the stories that we're hearing at the
moment in in the media and which of uh
are being properly investigated are
shocking because they are genuinely i
suspect a failure of leadership and they
need to acknowledge that it is perfectly
respectable on the one hand to be able
to fight but on the other hand you need
to do it in a sensible and civilized way
and that matters on the battlefield as
well because if we lose sight of our
values and standards on the battlefield
and if we lose sight of the importance
of the rules of war then we will lose
the moral high ground in relation to our
opponents and that's pretty fundamental
as well we've seen in recent days
allegations and in fact they're pretty
well founded of the behavior of troops
in
kenya
it's a it's a scandal really isn't it
and the allegations are truly shocking
um and um it's absolutely vital that we
get to the bottom of them as quickly as
possible and that those who are guilty
if they are guilty of those allegations
are brought to trial and we're going to
cooperate very closely with the kenyan
authorities to make sure that um that is
resolved as quickly as it possibly can
be there is a sense that the behavior
of some of our service people
particularly men
uh
is is such that they seem to think that
actually because they play this
incredibly important role they're
allowed to do all sorts of other things
and that has both
that bring the army and the other
services into disrepute it also by the
way i imagine discourages women from
joining and wanting to stay in the armed
forces this this is all bad the bottom
line is that you cannot have um the sort
of culture that leads to
this sort of behavior and these sort of
allegations you know it's fundamentally
disgraceful
and in no way
can the armed forces
be happy if that occurs
it will be a deterrent to all sorts of
things that we espouse and we must get
to the bottom of it